foreign
[Music]
to San Francisco yesterday for my speech
at uh Berkeley tonight we had to drive
downtown from the airport to get to our
hotel the GPS it wasn't working but
fortunately we were able to follow the
stench of weed and feces and it led us
right into the city
truly San Francisco Is A god-forsaken
Wasteland it is like something out of
Mad Max but way gayer
if you didn't know any better you might
think that the whole city is like some
kind of penal colony
if I had to choose between going to
prison or moving to San Francisco it
would be a flip of the coin at least
because there is no discernible
difference between the two this is what
a leftist Utopia looks like and what it
smells like like urine and garbage and
despair so what I'm trying to say is
that I'm not a big fan of this city and
so it should come down as no surprise
that I am canceling the city today
though my reason for canceling has
nothing to do with the trauma that I
suffer every time I'm forced to come
here uh it is it's really a coincidence
perhaps Providence that I happen to be
in the city on the day when it's reason
for cancellation has presented itself
and here's that reason it's a report
from the local ABC affiliate in San
Francisco it says San Francisco mayor
London breed announced the launch of a
new guaranteed income program for the
city's transgender community on
Wednesday the guaranteed income for
Trans people gift program will provide
low-income transgender residents with
one thousand two hundred dollars each
each month up to 18 months to help
address Financial insecurity within the
community
in a statement the city of San Francisco
said gift is one of several programs the
city is developing implementing and
evaluating to identify how to best
support San Francisco residents and
promote economic stability and Recovery
City also said that the new pilot
program is the first guaranteed income
initiative to focus solely on trans
people and will provide 55 eligible
participants with temporary income
additionally the city said it will
provide the same individuals with wrap
around Direct Services such as gender
affirming medical and Mental Health Care
case management specialty care services
and financial coaching
now we're told the reason for this
program is that trans people are
disproportionately impacted by poverty
we already know that trans people are
disportially impacted by by everything
really if there was a giant tsunami that
obliterated the whole city not to get
your hopes up and everyone was washed
away in the process we would still be
told that trans people were
disproportionately impacted if a volcano
erupted on an island in the Pacific and
incinerated a small village of 600
people and there were no trans people in
the village at all we would still be
told that trans people were
disproportionately impacted somehow
as for poverty the article says this
quote
we know that our trans communities
experience much higher rates of poverty
and discrimination so this program will
target support to lift individuals in
this community up we will keep building
on programs like this to provide those
in the greatest need with the financial
resources and services to help them
Thrive said mayor London breed in a
statement transgender communities
experience poverty and economic
stability instability at
disproportionately uh High rates
according to the city the U.S
transgender survey which is which is the
only large-scale study of trans people
in the U.S in 2015 found that 33 of
trans people in California were living
in poverty
all right
so we're supposed to assume that the
higher rates of poverty in the trans
Community are due to you know
discrimination transphobia whatever even
in a place like San Francisco where
trans people are literally worshiped as
deities even here it's uh the the high
rates of poverty are because of bigotry
yet even the left will acknowledge that
trans people they also have higher rates
of mental illness and substance abuse
issues
that would seem to explain why they're
more likely to have trouble holding down
a job
and it's hard to see how handing them a
check for 1200 bucks will solve that
and by the way if we're if we're
providing Financial advantages to groups
that are more likely to be homeless and
impoverished why not set up a program
giving a monthly stipend to men
quote cisgender men specifically after
all
uh men as compared to women
suffer much higher rates of homelessness
and and similar conditions
so why not give them a program
but no such program would or ever could
exist because the disproportionate
impact game is rigged
in any case we still haven't gotten to
the reason for this cancellation
you know obviously
handing out free money to the gender
confused is an insane idea that will not
solve any problem and will only make the
existing problems even worse but if San
Francisco wants to continue its March
into insanity and Oblivion it is more
than welcome to do so I have no interest
in talking sense into them nor could I
even do that anyway that's why my focus
is not on the program itself
but on the form you have to fill out in
order to be eligible for it
you know sending data over an
unencrypted internet connection it's
like sending a postcard your message is
wide open to the mailman and any other
nosy individual that you see whether
you're connected to an unencrypted
internet Network on your phone computer
tablet or TV you're sending countless
pieces of information out into the
digital world that can be seen and
intercepted by pretty much anyone a VPN
creates a secure tunnel between your
device and the Internet it's like
putting your postcard in an envelope so
that nobody can read your letter before
it gets to the person you're sending it
to expressvpn is the VPN that I trust to
keep my data secure expressvpn creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so that hackers
can't steal your personal data you know
your passwords your financial details
anything else hackers make serious cash
selling personal information on the dark
web but expressvpn makes it easier than
ever to keep your information safe just
fire up the app click one button and
you're instantly protected it's as
simple and easy as that plus expressvpn
works on all of your devices so you can
stay secure on the go secure your online
data today expressvpn.com Matt walshell
and get three extra months free that's
expressvpn.com Matt walshow
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
so if you want to take advantage of gift
you must complete a 10 page form which
is available online in PDF form so you
can go see it and the reason why you
might think like 10 pages that's uh
that's a lot of pages why do you have to
fill out 10 pages well
the reason that it's 10 pages
that becomes immediately obvious when
you skim through it
for instance you're asked to provide
your pronouns and the form gives you 15
options including Coco's
zims is per per pers and V ver VIs
now these may sound like characters in a
Dr Seuss book but instead they are in
fact made up pronouns now what is a v
verb exactly and how is it distinguished
from a z Zim or a perpers nobody knows
nobody can say
and of course if 15 options aren't
enough you can also check not listed as
an option
yeah the list of pronouns seems
downright limited compared to the
section for gender identity
there are according to Libs of tick tock
we took the time to count them all God
bless her there are 97 provided options
for gender identity 97 genders
and now In fairness they've padded the
stats here quite a bit uh there will be
in many cases four or five different
ways to phrase the exact same thing such
as transgender woman woman of trans
experience woman with a history of trans
of gender transition or trans feminine
these are treated as discrete and
distinct identities yet they're all the
same brand of nonsense rephrased in
various different ways other gender
options include
sister girl
feminine of Center
brother boy Zeno gender
gender Outlaw is an option you can be a
gender outlaw
multi-gender Omni gender
Novi gender she really identify with the
if you really love the the month of
November I guess you're a Novi gender
and also there's a gender called
aggressive
that's that's the agenda aggressive
aggressiveness is its own gender now and
if somehow none of those work for you
you can always check I don't use labels
or not listed
and then what about sexual orientation
well here there are a quaint 17 options
um a number inflated by the fact that
non-monogamous pansexual and polyamorous
are all listed as separate options
another sexual option on a sexual
orientation option on the list and I'm
just telling you this okay this is this
is what's on the list this is what this
government form says this is a valid
label according to the form
and the label is [ __ ]
that is on the sexual orientation
checklist don't shoot the messenger I'm
just I'm telling you what the form says
that is now a sexual orientation that
you can claim and then get twelve
hundred dollars from San Francisco if
you do
now
I've often said that uh many of these
new gender and sexual orientation labels
are not really genders orientations but
actually personalities and there are
others who say that there are not
genders sexual orientations or
personalities but really are mental
illnesses and I think both are the case
you know you don't have to choose
between the two but there's something
else too
um in in many cases take someone who
identifies as a pansexual multi-gender
Demi boy with am pronouns I think it'd
be almost making too much of it to call
it a personality or a mental illness
it's almost giving it too much credit
because this is actually just nothing at
all it doesn't mean anything
in so many cases genders and pronouns
now are like Hobbies these days it's a
recreational activity
people who have nothing better to do
just
sit around coming up with and collecting
new labels for themselves it's like this
generation's Pokemon cards
except it comes with a with a you know
extra side of identity crisis
and maybe
this is partly why San Francisco has so
many homeless people
can't get jobs
because the entire city is sitting
around thinking about its pronouns and
gender identities these are the kinds of
things they're thinking about
don't have the time to think about or
worry about anything else like getting a
job or you know
housing for example
I think there may be more to that theory
than you think but we're not going to
flesh it all out now for now suffice it
to say that San Francisco is for this
reason and so many countless others
canceled
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts